ROMAN NURIK: Hello, and welcome
once again to "Android
Design in Action." I'm your
host Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: And hi, my
name is Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And today we're
going to be talking about
designing collections.
Collections specifically, I
guess we're talk about what we
mean by collections in a second,
but collections are
all about lists, and presenting
lists of objects
and collections of things,
groups of objects.
Anyway let's just jump in.
So like I said collections are
really just groups of objects
of I guess things like a list
of items in a shopping cart,
or a list of books,
things like that.
So today we're going to be
talking about a couple things.
I guess we're going to be
talking about consumption of
collections as well as mutation
of collections.
By consumption of collections,
I really mean things like
being able to view a collection
obviously, being
able to search through it,
filter through it, things like
that, as well as things like
responsive design for
collections, and Nick will
do a bit about that.
And then also, we're going to
talk about mutations of
collections, specifically ways
in which you can allow users
to add items, remove items from
a collection, reorder
them as well as take action on
certain items in a collection.
All right.
So I know that was a
super fast intro.
Before we jump into all these
specific details, we just want
to look at one thing first
is basic presentation.
So throughout the rest of these
slides, throughout the
rest of today's episode, we're
going to be looking at very
specific details but from
a very high level.
This is stuff that we obviously
already talked about
in the past, but we're going to
be looking at collections
from a number of different
viewpoints.
Obviously, you know you can
use a list to present a
collection of objects and grid
to present a list of objects
or a collection of objects as
well as something like a
ViewPager, like swipe between
different items within a
collection.
We're going to be focusing
on the first two here.
We're not going to spending
too much time on the
ViewPager, the swiping
between items.
So just kind of keep that
in mind, I guess.
Before we jump in, Nick do you
want to add anything to that
super fast intro?
NICK BUTCHER: No.
As you said, we're not going to
talk about what a list is,
what a grid is.
We're more kind of go through
the options you have on
Android for working with
these collections,
doing things to them.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
All right.
So let's jump in to collection
consumption.
Nick, do you want to talk about
collection consumption?
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
Absolutely.
So here we've kind of called
this section distillation.
So this is when you're acting
upon items where in the
collection kind of refinements
and so forth.
And so we pulled up three
examples here on the slide,
the first of which is a quick
way to kind of section and
navigate around content
with a collection.
And so some standard ways of
doing that on Android, we've
pulled out working from left
to right, first off we have
this combination of headers with
an index fast scroll bar.
So in this example here, we're
using the People app.
They're your list of
your people, and
contacts, and so forth.
So you can see that each of the
letter of the alphabet has
a section, and this instance is
using a pass that we call
sticky headers.
So you can see here that e has
stuck to the top and will stay
in place until it's scrolled
out of view by the next
section here after that.
Combine that with a quick scroll
from as a fast way to
navigate these kind of long
lists of quite structured data
that work quite well if your
data is a good match of that.
It doesn't work so well if your
data doesn't have such a
kind of rigid and expected
structure.
So it depends on your
data needs whether
that will all work.
The next kind of distillation
method, which is called on
Android we're using this
kind of view change.
It's using one of the facilities
of the action bar
which allows you to
kind of flip the
representation of the data.
So in this example, we're using
the Gallery application,
which let's you view your
collection of photos as either
a grid of photos or you can get
this cool kind of zoomed
out film strip view where you
can see them one main photo
mainly at a time, we'll have to
cut more peeking in on each
side and quickly fling
between them.
So yeah.
Here we're using the action
bars spinner all have
drop-down control in order to
provide this kind of switch of
views or flip a view type.
And the last kind of
distillation action that I'm
going to talk about
is sorting.
So in this example here on the
right from a foreign rep side
of ADIA, we're using an action
bar button in order to reveal
a sub menu to do some sort.
So if you see the kind of the
three lines action buttons,
the standard iconography on
Android for sorting, pressing
that reveals a sub menu which
lets you pick how you want the
data sorted.
So pretty simple stuff.
These are the common ways on
Android in which you can do
these kind of distillation-type
behaviors.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
And one more thing I wanted to
mention is that another way to
do the view change is to have an
Action Bar button that lets
you toggle the view, but
actually I find that what
Gallery does here is actually
kind of neat.
It kind of expresses both the
title of the current screen as
well as the type of view all in
the top-left kind of View
Details area, which is
this kind of a neat
way to expose that.
And then any time you press the
spinner and make a change,
only the subtitle
I guess changes.
The top title camera doesn't
change which is pretty cool.
NICK BUTCHER: Definitely.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Moving on.
NICK BUTCHER: So some more
types of distillation
we have here is--
and these are kind of slightly
different to the previous
types in that these distillation
actions were
actually apped upon the items so
it will refine or show less
items rather than just
flipping to another
representation really
So it's more kind of
like filtering behavior.
So the first off column 1 used
the kind of standard searching
behavior in order to just
filter through the items
already shown on screens.
So in our example, we're going
back to the People application
again where you can start
searching for a contact.
So this works really well for
large data sets where if you
had to pick from a list, the
drop-ins, it might be too
large or too kind of
nonspecific, so search can
work quite well there.
The next up is a simple kind of
filter switch where you're
changing kind of on discrete
filterable things.
So in our example here, we're
using pocket which let's you
select and store different
kinds of media for later
consumption.
And they use this kind of corpus
switch filter to kind
of filter down just to kind of
articles, videos, images, I'm
looking at media type, so that's
a pretty common one.
And again, that's implemented
as an action
from the action bar.
So pressing the action
reveals a sub menu.
And in this particular visual
design pocket, I've chosen to
use the kind of the right
pointing down on right kind of
arrow to kind of display either
there are other options
here, which is kind
of optional.
We see it similar to sorting
behavior in that you don't
necessarily need to have
that drop-down option.
ROMAN NURIK: And another area
where this is used, this kind
of bottom-right triangles would
be ShareActionProviders.
So if you have a custom or
I guess if you use the
ShareActionProvider or the share
pack as it's sometimes
known as, and you press the
button, it actually shows kind
of an anchored list as well.
So it's a very similar
presentation, so it's quite
often coupled together.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
And it's got quite the support
in the platform of [INAUDIBLE]
so it's easy to implement this
kind of stuff using sub menus.
And the last one which is my
favorite ones is using this
right side d in order
to provide
some filtering behavior.
So again, this screen shot is
from an earlier episode of
"Android Design in Action" where
we went quite in depth
about its topic.
But I'm a big fan of this
because it has a lot of the
benefits of the drawer.
And left-hand drawer will have
a navigation as it can for
actions on the right-hand
side.
So some of those benefits are
very kind of as it appears,
kind of in Chrome level, so it's
above the content in a
way, which is great for
filtering in my opinion.
Because you can see they're
acting at a level above the
content rather than inline
with the content.
And what's more if your data
supports it, you can imagine
changing these filtering
settings and seeing the kind
of content behind the update
live, the number of results is
displayed, producing, and so
forth, which that kind of
instant response is a great
thing to provide.
So in this instance, we as with
the navigation drawer,
you have an affordance in the
action bar, so here we have a
filter icon.
But this would also be
accessible by a kind of an
edge swipe, a X swipe, a Bezel
swipe from the side, on,
giving real quick and
instant access to
the filtering options.
ROMAN NURIK: So one quick note,
actually two quick notes.
The first is if you want more
details on the specific
design, look at the past episode
titled "GDG Oslo." I
think we also covered brand
consistency in that episode,
but this is from that episode.
And the second thing was, a
live example of the actual
interaction could be found in
the Google+ app, the way in
which they do notifications.
They use this type of
interaction for notifications,
but it's perfectly suitable for
other types of things, for
example, filtering.
Generally, not great for
navigation, for core
navigation.
That's really more for the
navigation jar, the left side
of the screen, I guess.
But for filtering, for
distillation of content in a
collection is a great option.
NICK BUTCHER: Absolutely.
ROMAN NURIK: Let's move on
to responsive layout.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So when we're talking about
collections, we have to kind
of have this extra dimension
that I had over the fact that
they're going to be
displayed on all
sizes and shaped devices.
So something like a list view,
for example, might work great
on a small device, but it's not
going to scale up terribly
well to a larger device
especially when you think
about say 10-inch tablets in
landscape orientation, lists
can be a pretty bad way of
displaying information because
you end up with these
excessively lot-wide list
items with lots of white
space and so forth.
So the first pretty simple thing
you can do is switching
up from say using the list
in a smaller device up to
something like a grid view
in the larger device.
So problematic, this is very
simple to do in Android.
Both of these list and grid
components kind of have that
common base so it's
very easy to do.
You just provided different
layouts, say over this size
web view, this representation
of my item rather than this
list type one uses
grid type one.
And this can work especially
well if you have very kind of
visual, like large images or
thumbnails, which you can use
to form these kind of
like grid items.
So this is one simple way in
which you can use the space
better to present
your collection.
If you want to go into details
about this pattern as well,
the last Google, Roman and
I gave a talk and we've
documented some code on
how you might go about
implementing this.
The next thing you might
consider doing is breaking out
into this kind of like staggered
representation.
So this is kind of like
the step up from going
from lists to grids.
This allows you to create a
more dynamic kind of more
appealing representation
of your collection.
It allows you to kind of
recognize that not every item
in your group might
be similar weight.
So in this example here, we're
showing some kind of news
story, if the story is
particularly relevant,
particularly pertinent to the
user, you might take this
opportunity to break out of the
standard rhythm and take
up say a couple of cells
and so forth.
And this is another kind of way
of just re-utilizing the
space, and that's available
to you when you go
on to larger devices.
ROMAN NURIK: Moving on.
NICK BUTCHER: Moving on.
You can use a combination
of these [INAUDIBLE]
all together and as you kind
of get more available
space to play with.
And one great example of this
is the third-party Out of
Pocket, which I think we've
mentioned on the show earlier
before, which is a really great
job of adapting to the
amount of space available
to it.
So starting on the left from
a small device, they use a
standard list-driven navigation
to kind of show a
collection of items.
But as they get more room, they
kind of break it out into
sharing grid view and then on
even larger devices, they
switch up to a stack
of grid view.
So as you can see here, this
avoids those problems of
having these awkwardly-wide
cells.
You can imagine if that list
view was just stretched all
the way across that tablet, it
would look pretty uninspiring.
And instead, if they see it as
an opportunity to make the
content kind of stand out and
use it to highlight stories,
which might be particularly
interesting to these.
So it's kind of great use
of the opportunity.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
So this is just a great example
of really kind of
having the content, kind of
having, I guess, constraints
on your content, making sure
that images are a certain
aspect ratio, making sure that
the content never, or the body
text never exceeds certain
number of characters per line
and kind of starting with
those constraints and
designing outward from there.
NICK BUTCHER: Yes.
As you were touching on here,
I'm just going to slide this
to show that when you're
thinking about displaying your
collections on this kind of
variety devices, you kind of
have to let go of a little bit
of the kind of strict control
of the layout.
And one technique that works
really well-- go on to the
next slide-- is to
use this kind of
center cropping technique.
So this is a technique which
will help you with your images
to make them scale from wider
to smaller devices and
sacrificing some kind of
complete control over the
pixel dimensions, but just
saying maintain this correct
aspect ratio and pick the right
kind of segment of the
image in order to display it
in the amount of space
available to cell item there.
So you use the center cropping
technique and really help you
to build these cell contents
of the individual
items in the group.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
This works really well for like
landscape photography or
images like these strips
of bacon here.
Doesn't work so well when you
have people's faces or other
things that have important
or other photos that have
important content around
the fringes.
I think we may have touched on
this in past episodes, but it
is definitely a very, very
important technique to use.
NICK BUTCHER: Of course there's
still ways to do that
with that kind of imagery.
You might just have to do a
pass at it first and store
some data about where the center
is rather than being
the physical center
of the image.
It might be you detect where the
faces are on the server or
something like that, and when
you deliver the image down,
you pass in some information.
So it let's you do the center
crop technique but without
using the actual center, using
a focal point instead.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely.
Or use the face detection,
definitely a good technique.
A little harder, a little more
difficult to implement for
developers since there's no
kind of like random or
arbitrary center crop.
It's just like kind of the
center of the photo or it kind
of centers around the photo,
but definitely some of that
can be done.
It's not incredibly difficult,
but it can be done.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
And so one of the techniques
that Google is moving towards
is what we like to call this
kind of inside out design.
It's a kind of more of a
change in mindset than
anything else.
It's thinking about your content
first, thinking about
what the information you're
trying to display, what your
building blocks are and building
outwards from there,
rather than starting with
a grid, starting with a
Photoshop with a canvas of a
certain size and then trying
to sort your information
into it.
It's kind of going the
other way around.
So in a lot of Google design
language, we're moving towards
these carts or these blocks
of content, these kind of
individual blocks
of content and
building from there outwards.
So we think about content, and
we're thinking it can have
different representation.
So it might have a big cart
here at one certain
size it might be.
It might have different sizes it
can be in like maybe small,
or tiny carts.
It might have different
landscapes it can be in.
But all of these are just
thinking about this is my
piece of content and here are
some ways in which it can
express itself, it can
draw itself, it
can represent itself.
And then once you can have those
building blocks, you can
then build outwards and then
see how they slot together.
So starting from the individual
one, you can place
it into a canvas on the screen
and then by using just simple
proximity rather than kind of
bounding boxes or kind of
support in Chrome, you can just
build them up into these
clusters of items.
You can build up your grouping,
your clustering of
items just by placing them
next to each other.
And then you can introduce this
variety of the different
representations.
So you might use different
orientations, different size
carts to denote something
might be more important.
So this item on the left might
be most relevant to me, and it
can take a different rhythm than
the rest of the items and
use that to kind of express
why the information is
important to me.
And the concept here really is
to build this up into these
canvases, which is like a
collection of items where the
canvas is more of a conceptual
thing rather than being kind
of bounded to how much screen
really is on device.
But it's more like an ideally,
this is the group of items
which want to be displayed
next to each other.
So then when it comes to
actually time to kind of show
this on device, the device might
show a portion of this
cluster at once to might be this
is the kind of portion of
items and I will be able to then
pass horizontally swiped
to move along and see more of
the cluster available to me.
Or in a larger device, I might
be able to take all of this
conceptual cluster of
items, and see them
all at once on screen.
So as I say here, it's kind
of like starting with the
smallest building blocks but
starting with your information
first and building outwards
rather than starting your grid
and trying to fit
information in.
So one example of looking at
from the Play Store of how to
represent a movie might be,
hey, here's a few ways in
which we know we can represent
the information that's
important to this movie like the
poster, a title, a price,
a description, a reason why
it's interesting to you.
And you build these different
building blocks, these
different sizes of which
you can express itself.
And then the device at run time
just kind of picks the
right representation to show
this cluster of information.
And it might be able to
show only one thing
on screen at a time.
It might be able to put it next
to this mode of stuff and
build up this cluster
of information.
But you at least start from
these building blocks, these
conceptual building blocks.
And that was just kind
of like a rapid run
through this approach.
If you want to learn more, we
did a whole show looking at
this kind of stuff when we
talked to some of the
designers who worked on the
Google Play applications.
So do go back and check out that
show if you want to hear
some more about how we at Google
have been using this
kind of inside out design
principle to design our
collections.
ROMAN NURIK: Excellent.
All right.
So with that, let's move on
to mutating collections.
So there's a couple of different
ways to mutate
collections.
What we mean by mutating is
allowing the user to make
changes to the collections.
And we're going to try to speed
through this since we
have very little time left.
But the first is the very basics
of adding or removing
content to or from
a collection.
So how can you do this?
The first pretty obvious way is
this example in the People
app, you simply have an action
bar item that allows you to
add something.
In this case, you're allowing
the user to add a group of
contacts or add a new group
that's going to have no
contacts for now.
And we'll talk about that
in a second with
some details there.
Another more kind of potentially
interesting way of
doing this, more useful way of
doing this, more contextual
way of doing this is to actually
place the affordance
to add new content in line.
So here in Google Play Music,
you'll notice the Create New
Station button is in line with
the actual stations.
And even better example is here
in Google Keep, which
will actually use quite a bit
throughout the next few
screenshots.
You'll notice here that in the
to-do list or in this kind of
a checklist, the next item, the
item that you are going to
be adding next, is kind of this
faded out almost semi
transparent item indicating
that it's not there.
It's almost like a
ghost of an item.
It's not there but click here or
touch here and start typing
your content, and it will
become a real item.
So it's almost kind of hinting
that to create a new item,
here is where you start entering
your information.
So this is a very kind of good
technique for allowing users
to add content in line with the
rest of the items in the
collection.
Another very good technique
for this is to
use the empty state.
So the empty state is something
we talked about in
last week's episode on
onboarding, but basically the
empty state is when you have
no content in a collection.
And we find that is one of the
biggest missed opportunities
across apps on Google Play is
that when there's new content,
the app either says, there's no
content, or sorry there's
no content, or just a loading
spin or something.
That's a great opportunity to
actually let the user fix that
problem, actually let them
populate that collection, let
them fix the problem
of the empty state.
So in here in Google Keep, if
you have no reminders, the
center of the screen actually
has this nice, big affordance,
this nice, big touch target
to create a new reminder.
Touching that actually
takes you to the
create a reminder flow.
So those are some basic ways
to add items to the
collection.
NICK BUTCHER: And I think quite
often people when think
about adding items they think
that's an action, adding is an
action, and therefore, up here I
know what action is going in
action bar.
But I think that can often be
kind of a missed opportunity.
I think these inline options
can often avail convey more
context with them.
I mean, this Google Keep one
in particular, you can know
exactly what it's going
to app there, what's
going to happen there.
It kind of conveys a lot more
information than just having a
simple button in
the action bar.
I could do a lot more.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
And the key there is context
and direct manipulation.
It really kind of helps satisfy
that design principle.
All right.
So sorry, folks.
I think we're having some
technical difficulties, but
now let's jump back into it.
So one thing I wanted to mention
when talking about
adding items specifically
exposing an action in the
action bar for that, is you
should try to, when possible,
show the actual icon
representing the object type
as well as a plus overlay
or plus suffix as
it's labeled here.
And this is really kind of
a platform convention.
It helps establish context for
what exactly you're adding.
Cases where you don't really
have a great iconic
representation of the content,
you could just show a plus,
but for sure, it's preferred to
show the plus as a suffix
again to establish context.
All right.
So let's move on to
removing items.
So there are number of different
ways to allow users
to remove or delete items
from a collection.
The first is using this kind of
contextual action overflow
that you would place inside
of your object.
And what happens is when the
user presses these three
little vertical dots, and
actually the touch region
should probably be expanded to
be about 48 dip, the bottom
right 48 dip of a screen, if
they touch that overflow,
they'll get in anchored pop up
menu of actions they could
take on that object.
So in this case, I'm looking
at a station on Google Play
Music, and if I press these
three vertical dots, I get
this delete action.
So that's one way to
delete something.
Another way is to trigger the
contextual action bar.
So here this is Gallery.
If you long press one of these
photos and then you can also
press other items that are
adjacent to select those as
well, you actually see the
contextual action bar up here
at the top of the screen, and
then you can choose to delete
those objects.
So these two things, the
contextual action bar and this
contextual action overflow, I
guess, these are also useful
for other things, but deletion
or removing an item from the
collections is one very
common way to do that.
Now, another way to remove
items is to use something
called swipe to dismiss or
swipe to remove, and this
works best in kind of like a
vertical list or horizontal
list of objects where if the
user starts swiping left or
right in a vertical list or up
or down in a horizontal list,
the object is removed
from the collection.
The nice thing here is that as
part of this interaction, as
part of this gesture, you can
also kind of have the adjacent
items slide in or animated in
to fill up the gap that was
left by the item that was moved
to help kind of convey
the concept that this thing has
been kind of removed from
this set of objects.
NICK BUTCHER: And I think this
kind of swipe to remove
pattern is a very visceral,
direct manipulation pattern,
so rather than operating
machinery like pressing a
button to remove something.
I'm actually like grabbing
the [INAUDIBLE] and
getting rid of it.
And it's kind of really
satisfying.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
Exactly.
NICK BUTCHER: It's also quite
prevalent in our system as
well, so like notification is
the recent stack, use it.
A bunch of basics used for
Android, so it's pretty
well-understood gesture
as well.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
So let's move on.
There's a bit more to say on the
contextual action bar, but
we'll talk about it in a bit.
So beyond just simply allowing
users to add or remove items
to or from a collection, one of
the things you may want to
do is allow them to reorder
things, reorder objects.
An example of this could be
personalizing kind of the
order of navigation sections
that you care about or
something as simple as
reordering a set of
tasks in a task list.
So let's talk about some of
the ways in which you can
allow users to do that.
The first is to use something
called like a drag grip.
So you want to send these first
two examples on the left
of your Google Keep.
On the right, you have
Google Play Music.
There's these three horizontal
little lines, and it's kind of
a smaller version of the
burger menu icon or the
navigation drawer icon, so we
kind of like to call it a
slider if you get the joke.
So this drag grip is basically
these three horizontal lines
that are vertically centered
within the object that you're
showing, and it's on
the left-hand side.
So if the user presses or
touches in that area, the
object kind of is picked up
momentarily, and the user can
kind of drag up and down
to reorder it.
So on the left, you'd reorder
a set of tasks.
On the right here, you would
potentially reorder items
within a play queue,
for example.
And Nick brought up this
earlier, kind of important
point around how this works
with the navigation jar.
One of the features of the
navigation jar is that if you
touch anywhere, if you're on a
screen with a navigation jar,
if you touch on the left side of
the screen, on the left 16
dip or so of the screen, the
navigation jar kind of peaks
in to indicate that
it's there.
And you'll notice actually that
with these drag grips,
they're also on the left
side of the screen.
So those are kind of two
overlapping touch regions.
So generally, if you have a
navigation jar and also want
to expose reordering with this
kind of drag grip approach,
you'll probably either want to
re-think what's most important
is offering the jar there most
important or the drag grip or
just place the drag grip on the
right side or somewhere
else within the item.
So that's a very important
point.
Another thing to note is that
this touch region is actually
very small, and since this is
a fairly important kind of
gesture, fairly important
action, you may want to
actually virtually extend
the touch region
to be about 48 dips.
So while it looks like it's
about 16 or 20 dips wide, you
may want to use something called
a touch delegate to
allow users to touch anywhere
within the left 48 dips of the
screen to allow reordering
or dragging.
So that's the drag grip and
we'll talk about presentation
of drag grip in a second.
But another way to do this and
actually this is another
example from Google Keep,
another way to allow users to
reorder is to allow them to
touch and hold to kind of pick
up the object, very similar to
how you would trigger the
contextual action bar.
But then once you touch and
hold and start moving your
finger around, the object starts
dragging around, so you
see the ghost image of the
object underneath the finger
and then you see kind of a
destination rectangle kind of
move around to indicate where
the object will land
when you let go.
So this is again slightly more
direct manipulation like.
It kind of fits that principle
quite a bit more.
But it's slightly less
discoverable since it doesn't
have an on-screen affordance.
NICK BUTCHER: Another thing you
just said, before we move
on, is it's important to
indicate when you enter this
mode as well.
So you need to do examples.
Once you start the drag action
so when you touch on the
slider menu or when you long
press on the item in Keep,
they visually react to it.
So in Keep, you see a kind of
ghost semi transparent, and it
actually kind of moves, I think,
about 16 dips up and
right or up and left.
It's physically like you've
picked it up almost.
And I just indicate that this is
what you're acting upon, so
it it's good to react
straight to it.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
Absolutely.
One thing I wanted to point
out here is that there's
actually two visual
presentations for the drag
grip, the first is this slider
that we call the little three
horizontal lines, a slightly
more common yet older style is
this kind of tire track where
basically you have these
little kind of boxes, two
columns of boxes or squares
aligned to the left
of the screen.
And the interaction is just
the exact same thing.
You basically kind of touch to
pick up and start dragging up
and down, but the visual
presentation is slightly different.
So this is slightly
older style.
This is a slightly
newer style.
Both are certainly
valid approaches.
All right.
So let's move on to
acting on items.
So this is kind of
the big one here.
This is actually kind
of a summary of a
couple of these things.
So acting on items, what we mean
here is, generally, an
object in a collection
has a single main, a
touch target itself.
When you touch on it, you show
the details for the object or
kind of take the
primary action.
Now, what if you have secondary
actions, other
things you can do
to that object?
And we touched on a couple of
these already but, the first
is to offer an action overflow
or a contextual action
overflow, I guess.
So you would have these
three vertical dots.
Like we said before, you touch
the overflow affordance, and
then you see a pop-up menu.
So this works well with the
secondary actions like delete.
Also things like if you're in
Google Play and you're looking
at an app, you can press the
three vertical dots to
immediately start installing
that app, also things like
edit or whatever you want, any
other things, share as well.
The contextual action bar is
certainly kind of the more
standard, more common approach
to doing this.
So what you do here is, you
select an object by long
pressing it and then the context
of the screen changes.
So your action bar changes into
this contextual mode and
then you can take action
from there.
For example, here you can long
press to pick up a note in
Google Keep and then change its
color sort of a reminder,
or archive it.
You'll notice that here in
Google Keep you can long
press, like I said before,
long press to pick it up.
If you don't move your finger
around, it just selects it and
lets you take action.
If you start moving your finger,
it will actually start
dragging it.
So these two are very,
I guess they work
in tandem, if possible.
NICK BUTCHER: And one of my
favorite things about the
contextual action bar is it's
a very easy way to act on
multiple items at once.
So you can imagine in the
Gallery example there, if you
long pressed on an individual
photo, it would offer one
selection of actions, which is
applicable to a single item.
But if you just quickly tap on
three extras, you have a group
force of exit.
You can very quickly access
them, very quickly share them,
and delete them, whatever it is
you want to do much quicker
than I'm going to have to go
into an item and perform an
action, come back up to the
group, then go do again.
So the contextual bar is very
powerful in that way.
ROMAN NURIK: One other note I
wanted to make here is that
rather than taking the action
first and then selecting which
objects you want to take action
on, like it is very
common in other platforms, on
Android it's really kind of
select first then take action.
The nice thing about this is
that it's very much direct
manipulation minded, right?
I mean, you start with the
content, you start with the
object, and then you
perform the action.
The other nice thing about the
contextual action bar here is
actually you can offer things
like Select All really easily.
So once you long press the
Select, you can offer like a
spinner in the action bar
offering the user to Select
All or Deselect or
things like that.
All right.
Moving on since we're running
super short on time.
Another very popular way of
offering a secondary action is
to offer something in line with
the list item running
along the right side
of the screen.
So here you'll notice that with
this individual object,
another action you could take is
make changes to it, change
its settings.
And this is offered as a
Settings icon all in the right
side of the screen.
You'll notice that there's a
little divider here, and this
serves the purpose of indicating
that there are two
distinct touch regions.
So if I touch here, one
thing will happen.
If I touch here, something
else will happen.
Another think you should keep
in mind when presenting this
type of UI is that you should
make sure that the entire
right side of the screen or
right side of this item is
dedicated to that secondary
action.
So if I touch above the icon
or below the Settings icon,
you should still trigger
the settings action.
And that's really to kind of
simplify the number of touch
regions or simplify the touch
regions on the screen and to
prevent human error
with touches.
NICK BUTCHER: And those are kind
of echoed by the touch
highlight, so that if you were
to touch on the main item, the
entire line will light up to
kind of like underscore the
fact this is the main action,
and if you touch on the
secondary reaction, just
the area up to the
divider will light up.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
One last thing I wanted to point
out here is another good
example of this since you know
this entire episode has been
driven by examples, we
wanted to see these
techniques used in action.
Another really good example of
this is in the contact details
screen, you manage your phone
probably has contacts app on
your Nexus device probably
the People app.
When you're looking at contact
details, if you look at a list
of phone numbers for a specific
contact, you'll
notice that each of those
phone numbers has an
additional secondary action on
the right to send a text
message to that number.
So the primary touch target, the
phone number itself, will
try to place a call
to that number.
But then if you touch on the
right-hand side, there's
little text message icon that
will actually take the users
to the composed text
message screen.
So lots of different
ways to offer
additional actions on objects.
So I think that about does
it for collections.
So we talked about a couple
things today.
We talked about specifically
kind of how you can offer
filtering, searching, sorting
through collections, I guess
the consumption side as well as
how to present collections
in a very responsive way.
And then we talked about a
mutation of collections,
adding/removing items,
reordering them, as well as
taking action on items within
a site of objects.
So that's about it for today.
With that, I'm your
host, Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: And bye from
me, Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: Thanks
for joining, guys.